الان وباذن المحكمه اطلب سعاده السيد
رونالد لامونا وزير العدل في
جمهوريه افريقيا لالقاء البيان الاستهلالي
لجنوب افريقيا اشكر وكيل جنوب افريقيا على
بيانه والان ندعو وزير العدل
والخدمات
الاصلاحيه الكلمه لك
سيدي شكرا
لك السيده الرئيسه اعضاء المقرون في
المحكمه انه فخر لي ان اقف امامكم اليوم
وبالنيابه عن جمهوريه جنوب افريقيا في هذه
القضيه الاستثنائيه ونحن نمد اي دينا الى
شعب الفلسطيني ونقوم بذلك مع
ادراك كامل لانسان تهم التي هي على المحك
هذا
ايضا ما تعلمناه من مؤسسنا نيلسون من
مندلا
ونحن فيما يتعلق بمنع جريمه الاباده
الجماعيه وانضممت لها في العام
1988 88 كانت هذه هي الروح التي انضممنا
فيها للاتفاقيه وكطر مصادق على هذه
الاتفاقيه هذا واجبنا تجاه الشعب
الفلسطيني وايضا تجاه الشعب الاسرائيلي
وكما ذكر انفا العنف والدمار في فلسطين
واسرائيل لم يبدا في السابع من اكتوبر في
العام 2023 انما الفلسطين قد اختبروا هذه
ال بشكل ممنهج
منذ 75 عاما ولكن منذ السابع من اكتوبر
2023 في قطاع
غزه مارست اسرائيل هجوما كبيرا برغم انها
منذ العام
20044 هي تحاصرهم وتقطع عنهم المياه
وال الكهرباء
اسرائيل تدخل برا وبحرا منعت الدخول برا
وبحرا الى غزه هنالك فقط معبرين الى غزه
واخذه عن الاعتبار
السيطره الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه اسرائيل
لا تزال تعتبر من قبل المجتمع الدولي هي
احتلال جهه
احتلال جنوب افريقيا تدين
استهداف
المدنيين من قبل حماس ومن غيرها من
المجموعات المسلحه الفلسطينيه
و اخذي او الرهائن في اكتوبر 7 اكتوبر
2023 وقد عبرنا عن ادانتنا
ومؤخرا في ال 21 من ديسمبر لاسرائيل ثلاث
شفهيا لا يجب ان يتم
هجوم على ايه ارض مهما كانت جدته
اعادته وهذا طبعا لا مبرر له ولا يعطي
مبررا لانتهاك الاتفاقيات التي نعن
بصددها اسرائيل وردها على هجمه السابع من
اكتوبر قد تجاوزت
الخطوط وايضا انتهكت الاتفاقيه ووفقا
للادله
وجبنا نحن ووفقا للماده الاولى من
الاتفاقيه حكومه دوله افريقيا افريقيا
قامت
بتقديم هذه الدعوه وجنوب افريقيا ترحبوا
بحقيقه بان اسرائيل منخرط في هذه القضيه
من اجل حل القضيه امام المحكمه وبعد
مراعاه دقيقه
للحقائق والحيثيات وكا طراف في
الاتفاقيه هذه المرافعه تتعلق
بطلب جنوب افري
للمحكمه لفرض
التدابير
المؤقته وستكون تركيزنا عليها تركيزا ضيقا
واقتبس مارتن لوثر كينج هنا عندما قال بان
اخلاق
ال منحنى اخلاق البشريه هو طويل ولكنه
يؤدي الى العداله